-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching our show.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, earlier today
President Biden was in Brussels
to meet with NATO leaders for
an emergency summit on Russia.
When they voted on a resolution
to condemn Putin,
30 leaders voted "yea," and one
office plant voted "nyet."
[ Laughter ]
Anyone see that plant walk?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was an emergency
summit, but don't worry.
NATO leaders still had time
for a family photo.
Here it is.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like the sales team at
a Honda dealership, doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
I'm expecting them to all
say together,
"We're ready to serve you."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see it again?
Yeah.
It's a very diverse group.
There are suits of every color.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's either a NATO
summit or a conference for
"men who don't know what to do
with their arms" photo.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see the photo
just one more time?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
Kind of doing his own thing.
-Yeah.
-Well, changing gears,
this morning the "Today" show
investigated the dangers
of the metaverse.
And they even sent
one of their reporters in
to see what kind of activity
goes on in there.
Let's see how that went.
-We wanted to see the concerns
for ourselves,
so I put on a headset and
entered the metaverse.
That blue robot is me.
There we entered
a virtual strip club,
created and uploaded
by another user.
-I am a reporter, yes, trying to
understand the metaverse.
-[ High-pitched voice ] Oh, you
should not have come in here.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-Amazing!
Billions spent on technology
so a cartoon weasel
can kick you out of
a fake strip club.
[ Laughter ]
[ High-pitched voice ] You
should not have come in here.
Oh, no.
Put your hands together
for Cinnamon, everybody.
[ Normal voice ] Some business
news -- due to a shortage of
ingredients, General Mills
is struggling to supply
grocery stores with
Totino's Pizza Rolls
and Pillsbury Cookie Dough.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
-It's serious.
As soon as he heard, Biden
called NATO back for
another emergency summit.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, when I heard there was
a T.P. shortage,
I wasn't thinking
Totino's Pizza.
[ Laughter ]
Right now General Mills is like,
"Hey, but we still have plenty
of Fiber One bars.
Hello? Anyone?
Anyone want to gnaw on
a Fiber One bar?"
[ Laughter ]
One vote said, "Nyet."
One office plant said, "Nyet."
-It was a spy. It was a Russian
spy, is what you're saying.
-What's that?
-It was a Russian spy
in that plant.
-Oh, is that correct?
-Yeah, that's what it was.
That's why it said, "Nyet."
-Oh, so you're saying it's
"30 world leaders said yes."
And then one office plant
said --
-"Nyet," which is "no"
in Russian.
-Yeah, and it was --
But a plant --
-So you're implying that it was
a spy in that plant.
That's what makes it
so humorous.
That's what I love about it.
[ Laughter ]
Topical.
-Yep, it is.
Hey, this is big though, guys.
Yesterday CEOs of every major
U.S. airline called on
President Biden to drop
the federal mask mandate.
-Ooh.
[ Applause ]
-Each airline actually released
its own statement about it.
Take a look.
American Airlines said,
"We've complied with the mask
mandate long enough."
United said, "It's time for
a return to normalcy."
Spirit Airlines said, "Wait,
there was a mask mandate?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And Delta said, "We believe
vaccine numbers are high enough
to drop the mask policy."
Then Spirit said, "Does
duct tape count as a mask?
'Cause if so, we've been masking
tons of people."
[ Laughter ]
JetBlue said, "We look forward
to seeing our passengers'
smiling faces again."
And finally, Spirit said,
"Passengers can smile?
Oh, now I've heard everything."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pretty out of the loop,
I don't know.
Hey, get this, I saw that Uber
has reached a deal
to list all New York City taxis
on its app.
And this makes sense --
they hashed out the deal
by screaming at each other
through open car windows.
"You want to sign the deal?
You sign it!"
You can't park there!
Sign the deal! You" --
[ Laughter ]
Hey, here's some good news.
I read that as kids
return to the classroom,
their test scores are going up.
It's a really nice way of saying
we all failed at homeschooling.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, first graders are already
coming home like,
[English accent] "Mother,
father, your homeschooling
efforts were rather deficient."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
I heard a new report about
where people like to eat food
in their house.
And the results might surprise
you. Check it out.
-According to a new survey
in the U.K.,
more than one in five people say
they snack in the bathroom.
18% confessed they enjoy
their treats on the toilet.
-No!
-What?!
-You know what?
Just take me back
to the metaverse.
I think I like that.
[ High-pitched voice ]
"Welcome back, Mr. Fallon.
Here's 70 Jimmy bucks for you
to make it rain."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Finally,
researchers say that they're
getting closer to producing
the first ever
birth control pill for men.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-That's better than the original
form of male birth control --
dress socks with sandals.